un autre personnage très important qui
est pressé qui devra nous quitte et
relativement rapide bas et il est avec
nous pour cette émission spéciale on le
remercie infiniment alors il s'agit de
harout chitilian qui vice-présidente du
comité exécutif de la ville ne m'ont
rien bonjour alors vous êtes vous êtes
le premier politicien à cette table et
vous aurez vous avez pas la langue de
bois vous est présentée ici présenté
deux choses notamment la plus importante
je pense une des plus importantes se
serait cogné à seulement deux choses
aujourd hui plus important il ya le
binam donc le bureau d'intégration des
nouveaux immigrants montréal qui a
réalisé une enquête et vous avez annoncé
les résultats hier après midi en sortant
qu'est ce que vous avez à nous annoncer
ou à nous à nous présenter au niveau de
ce qui se passe pour les nouveaux
arrivants ici un moyen qui cherchent du
travail absolument donc avant tout c'est
une approche qui est personnalisé parce
que le sondage devait servait à
actualiser l'offre de services de la
ville de montréal et surtout de cibler
les groupes qui ont vraiment besoin de
notre accompagnement parce que les
données sont probants et démontre que
ceux qui ont le statut de résidents
permanents font leurs devoirs et il se
prépare et ils viennent ici préparer
pour affronter l'intégration alors que
vous avez 68 mêmes personnes qui sont
des résidents temporaires mais qui ont
un intérêt à rester ici soit ils sont
des étudiants étrangers sur cd visitant
qui veulent rester c'est soit c'est des
travailleurs qui sont hissés sur des
contrats d'emploi et la ville a intérêt
à collaborer à accompagner ces gens-là
cours également faire le choix de rester
ici parce que c'est des gens qui sont
vraiment scolarisés et qui amène plus vu
la communauté montréalaise toujours
cette question de la rétention et là
vous auriez quelque chose de nouveau
alors proposé puis ça va dans le courant
de l'air du temps parce que au niveau
haut niveau maintenant de la
numérisation de nos outils
bien sûr nous ne vous arrive à marseille
pour en témoigner
l'informatique c'est comme ça qu'on
rejoint on se console kinect pourront se
connecter au à la société qu'est ce que
vous avez à proposer d'accord donc
l'autre information qui est intéressante
dans le sondage c'est que dans le groupe
de résidents temporaires
le groupe d'âge qui est le plus
intéressé à faire le choix du québec de
montréal c'est les 18 25 ans et pour
rejoindre ce groupe là il faut
nécessairement et obligatoirement passer
par le numérique donc l'outil qui a été
lancée y en a qui s'appelle nouveau
départ c'est un outil personnalisé qui
permettra aux résidents temporaires ou
risban permana d'aller chercher de
l'information personnalisée sur leurs
besoins mais également d'établir des
liens privilégiés avec des personnes
potentielles qui pourront les aider dans
leur intégration et dans la rétention de
nîmes - cas d'accord dont vous arrivez
ici vous êtes un résident temporaire
vous voulez connaître avant tout aussi
beaux diplômes sont reconnus avril quand
j'essayais l'étape donc quelles sont les
modalités
quelles sont les offres professionnelles
à communiquer est ce qu'il ya des gens
qui peuvent vous accompagner dans cette
démarche
deuxième question qu'on se pose
également ceci à d'autres personnes
qu'on va amener qu'elles sont des étapes
pour faire la réunification des familles
mais également les ressources de
quartier parce que vous êtes vous
installé dans un quartier c'est un
quartier qui est vivant qui a déjà des
services de proximité en termes de
logement en termes également de loisirs
depuis
tout ça donc toute cette information la
personnaliser dorénavant doit être
disponible sur une plateforme dédiée aux
nouveaux arrivants et c'est comme si
vous aviez un numéro de membre puis un
mot de passe et plus vous aurez toujours
accès à ces informations
allez vous rester quelque part en ligne
pour vous si vous en avez besoin
donc la plateforme initialement une
plateforme qui ne nécessite pas de
l'authentification dont vous allez là
vous mettez vos profils et on vous donne
l'information mais hatem 7 la tombola
est appelée à évoluer pour devenir
beaucoup plus performant et surtout
viard il y avait beaucoup de personnes
qui circulaient ici pour justement
collecter les impressions et fin déjà
des améliorations et imprimeur hier
seulement dans les quelques heures qui
sont circulées ici on a eu 130 light et
le direct c'est très important de nos
jours donc la plateforme a eu 130 la
virtuelle des gens qui sont bio
on a combien de l'aigle 2-2 beaucoup
c'est très écouté je suis extrêmement
ravi de voir que vous allez avoir c'est
aussi qui va vous permettre de mieux
connaître le client parce que après tout
si tu es saison seulement voulu aider ou
l'aider mais vous allez vous aider vous
même on va tous cdc quelque chose il
faudrait s qui est un endroit où peut
aller pour voir ça pour tester court
pour jouer donc sur le site web de la
ville de montréal on va juste aller
chercher l'onglet nouveau départ en
français et new beginning en anglais
hello primeur et ça c'est une ville qui
est francophone fonctionnement rien de
la deuxième grande ville frappe
fondement mais en même temps pour cette
plate forme là on a fait pour la
première fois une exception donc il y as
oui le sport n'a regret mais il ya
également un outil numérique qui est
supporté par google qui permet la
traduction dans plusieurs langues
donc c'est également un prix main donc
la ville de montréal actualise ses
outils numériques pour également
permettre de la visualisation de ces
données en plusieurs langues o de la
france et ça mérite un article de la
part de radio canada
en national c'est pas moi qui prends les
décisions mais comme c'est moi qui écris
les articles gens faisaient là dessus
alors merci beaucoup à votre tâche et il
ya qui est vice président du comité
exécutif de la ville de montréal je vous
laisse filer vous avez un univers à
conquérir